what is the ratio of attention that you
get from guys versus girls
oh like 90 10. in favor of men of course
literally and I think my Instagram
statistics are like 91 men
yeah anyone who thinks that this life is
Gonna Get You girls
what does it say that like the king of
the Aesthetics bro era is just swimming
in men yeah like there's just men
everywhere and all of these guys that
think I'm gonna go to the gym and I'm
gonna if I get buffed then I'm gonna get
loads of attention from girls which also
there's there's a line of respect in
that because let's say you start doing
something for the attention of women and
then in the end you don't get it but you
realize how much you love it so you see
keep doing it and your brothers are like
that's dope and like you're not doing it
so your Bros love you but you're doing
it now because you actually love to do
it rather than just getting a girl you
know yeah so there's like a little bit
more meaning in doing it for yourself
and just because you love training come
for the girls stay for the games exactly
yeah yeah but it's dude it's just so
funny like every person that I've spoken
to that's in that's got a big platform
that is built around the physique it's
like
it's a lot of men every time a lot of
men out there that like are you getting
requests for sock they said please send
me your used socks please I used to but
I don't I don't read my DMs anymore okay
I don't really go through Calvin's job
the poor guy I'm the only one logged
into my stuff he sent me the stuff I
post it okay but I just don't even dive
into it there's too much [__] in there
there's gonna be it's a cesspool down
there Chris there's all these like
groups now and it's just like memes and
tags and like there's not even like
anyone actually saying anything what do
you mean like people will start a group
yep with like all their boys and then
like lifting club and it will be you and
your friends from high school and then
there's stroker's mom said in there
because it's funny maybe he'll see it
one day and I have like hundreds of
those and that's all I really and
they're not even messaging me they're
messaging each other and I'm just in the
chat
so I'll like I have like every couple
months I'll let go and I'm like bored
waiting someone I like looking I'm like
nope
there's just nothing in there yeah [__]
yeah what um
talking about social media in the social
media game something that you guys like
pay attention to uh to continue to build
how have you dealt with the increasing
amount of
notoriety and and pressure and eyes on
you and stuff as somebody that's pretty
heavily introverted and yeah once
they're privacy you've had to make
public relationship with Mrs business
you know the most stressful times of
your sporting career and stuff as well
yeah
how does that feel like have you
struggled with that and how's it helped
you to grow I think honestly
unlike most in that position it's
impacted me less than a lot of other
[__] my life has impacted me I think I
was just raised purely for like valuing
people who know who you are and who they
like who you are as a man and how you
like act in this world rather than what
you accomplish and what you own and all
these things
and all these people don't know who I am
so even from a young age I literally
remember thinking like all these
compliments I'm getting these people
don't even know who I am these people
don't even like they can say whatever
they want about me but it's just this
idea of me they're talking about not
actually me so the compliments well I'm
grateful for it and the support and it
means a lot to me they don't know who I
am it doesn't make me better or worse
whatever they say so when negativity
comes in and people say anything bad
it's it's they're both wanted the same
they're both just kind of like out there
and it doesn't really mean anything you
know if like my mom came up to me and
like you're being a really [__]
shitty person I'd like what the [__]
like I would like my heart would think
you know I would change my whole life
but like if someone on the street comes
up and be like you're this that I'd be
like
you don't even know me yeah like what
but how do you
you know that your mind isn't actually
going to gravitate toward these meaner
comments we have this negativity bias
that we see yeah
how have you trained yourself do you do
you not look is there a strategy behind
this for how you try and avoid the that
seeping in I imagine if you're three
weeks out from prep with everything in
the toilet and you feel like crap and
you've got 1500 calories to look forward
to today half of which is from broccoli
like the last thing that you want to see
is someone saying something mean on the
internet for sure yeah so why do you go
to deal with that
um I mean it's been there's a lot of
things and it's been a tradition but now
at this point when I'm in prep I mute
everything all notifications are off I
don't look at my comments I don't really
look at anything and I would just rather
that not seep into me kind of Baseline I
can always bring myself back to like
what I said understanding these people
don't know me but I'm obviously still
affected by certain things that hit me
but again if something affects me it's
because of something I have unhealed
inside of myself it comes back to like
where I'm where I'm still hurting not so
much what other people are what they're
thinking of me so like an example of
something that hit me a few years ago
but it was it wasn't online it was
someone in person and they were just
[__] around me were bantering where
guys were like you know we give each
other [__] and he said something like oh
wow when you were a kid like girls must
have been like you're just good looking
tall jacked handsome guy come up to him
and then you open your mouth and they
hear you your voice in that lip and
they're like what the [__] and they're
immediately they're like this [__] this
guy and they leave you alone and I
remember like feeling like a kid again
just getting washed over embarrassment
and just like feeling like [__] like
12 years 15 years old again and I was
like wow like I'm just like I used to be
teased a little bit for my list and I'm
like that's still kind of in there a
little bit but that's not because this
guy's an [__] that's because when I
was a kid someone made me feel like [__]
about it and I never really like gave
that kid like the love and permission
myself being that kid the love and
permission to like be okay with that and
understanding that doesn't represent
himself so I think just taking those
moments and using them as an opportunity
to go inside yourself and kind of like
a give your like younger self a little
bit of love and compassion who like
didn't get it maybe when he was younger
because he felt like alone be able to go
back and try and heal those periods of
your life rather than being angry at the
other person
because I mean that's really all that is
to it because if you're given the power
to the person then you're just focusing
on them and you're going to continuously
live in that pain it doesn't help you
and they don't give a [__] they're just
throwing [__] at you they don't care
what they want you to react in other
news this episode is brought to you by a
product I've used every single day for
over three years now and that is ag1
it's a foundational nutrition supplement
that covers whole body Health helps with
my digestion it helps with my energy it
is the staple to my supplement regime
and it's the same for Dr Andrew human
Joe Rogan Lex Friedman Tim Ferriss all
of them have been using it for a very
long time and that's because they invest
in the highest quality ingredients
they've upgraded the recipe 52 times
over the last decade as new researchers
come in also there is a 90-day
money-back guarantee so you can buy it
and try it for 89 days and if you do not
like it they will give you your money
back if you're looking for a simpler
effective investment for your health try
ag1 get five free ag1 travel packs plus
a year Supply vitamin D and that 90-day
money-back guarantee by going to
drinkag1.com
wisdom that's drink ag1.com wisdom